corona sommer 2020 deutschland macht
urlaub vor der haustür
[Musik]
auch hier gibt es wüste karibik kleine
abenteuer
und große schätze
mit dem weiten hinterland vorpommerns
lockt eine urlaubsregion die gerade erst
erwacht zwischen demmin und anklang
inmitten des peene und tollensetal es
erstreckt sich eine unberührte
flusslandschaft massentourismus gibt es
hier noch keinen vorsichtig wachgeküsst
sanft und nachhaltig soll der tourismus
sein
das schloss schmarsow in kroko viel
platz wenig besucher maximale erholung
das ist das konzept ist das
familientauglich familie köln aus berlin
hat nicht nur einen sondern gleich vier
teenager im gepäck sohn hanns hatt drei
freunde überredet mitzukommen
andrea wicken farbig die schlossherrin
nimmt ihre gäste noch ganz persönlich in
empfang und mama silke köln ist immer
zufriedener mit diesem corona
notfallplan dolce vita in vorpommern
doch die totale abgeschiedenheit wird
zum sozialexperiment entschleunigung als
pflichtprogramm im letzten alten dorf in
italien hat man wahnsinnig tollen
empfang da haben die kinder pokémons
gejagt meiner alpen wanderung die wir da
hatten im piemont westen ja da an der
brücke stand war auch plötzlichen
pokémons war total absurd und hier bis
zu mitten in deutschland das ist dann
schon ein bisschen verblüffend sagen wir
mal so ich wollte einmal am tag meine
mails checken weil so richtig von der
arbeit weg bin ich eigentlich nicht das
wird dir vielleicht ein bisschen
schwierig aber dann dachte ich eben auch
also dann eben nicht ein ganz neuer
gedanke dann eben nicht
dann eben nicht dann eben anders das
lernen wir deutschen in diesem corona
sommer mullerup geht auch zu hause fast
so wie früher auch die freizeitplanung
für den abend gehört neu überlegt wenn
kein netflix in den schlaf liegt hier im
vorpommerschen hinterland kann die natur
am besten vom boot aus beobachtet die
weitverzweigte flusslandschaft ist
lebensader eines der größten niedermoor
gebiete mittel und westeuropas ein
paradies nicht nur für biber so schön
das naturpark ranger günther hoffmann
sich längst sorgen macht und das was
jetzt hier entstanden es so einen
nachhaltigen naturtourismus hat
eigentlich die qualität dass es sich
langsam entwickelt und wenn man sich die
naturlandschaften hier ankommt muss man
auch sagen dass die touristische
entwicklung hier auch grenzen hat weil
wir dürfen ja nicht dass gefährden
von was wir eigentlich leben
davon ist
wahrscheinlich
der amazonas des nordens wird die pläne
auch genannt hier zeigt sie sich von
ihrer schönsten seite sommer in berlin
nein danke touristen sind in berlin
wegen corona immer noch rar und die
einheimischen brechen ihr lieber auf
raus aus ihrer stadt
die beiden feuerwehrmänner mit die und
thilo wollen für eine woche in
männerurlaub sind kollegen und kumpel
zugleich wenn man als team arbeitet der
muss man gut zusammenarbeiten der muss
man so verstehen wir verstehen uns jetzt
besonders gut wird dessen klappte dorf
und der privaten nicht zum ersten mal
entdecken sie die heimat zusammen mit
dem fahrrad einfluss fahrradtour macht
ich war schon so viel in deutschland
unterwegs und ich freue mich etwa wenn
eine neue gegend entdeckt und dort gibt
man so viele sachen zu sehen
mit der bahn geht es nach bayreuth von
hier wollen sie den main bis zur mündung
in den rhein fahren
entlang der strecke traditionsreiche
urlaubsregionen wie frankenwald
steigerwald oder spessart urlaub wie vor
30 jahren
und natürlich bei bestem deutschen
sommerwetter gleich ihr erster stopp ist
ein highlight zumindest für kultur
touristen aus aller welt
wagner stadt bayreuth das festspielhaus
die festspiele fallen in diesem jahr
erstmals seit 70 jahren aus wegen
corolla
man hofft auf alternativ touristen wie
micky und thilo
[Musik]
die götterdämmerung hier auf dem so
genannten grünen hügel mit ihr und thilo
beide berufsfeuerwehrleute in berlin
kann sie nichts anhalten
sie müssen auch weiter zu ihrem
zeltplatz sinti spät dran von bayreuth
aus geht es richtung norden und ihr
fahrrad abenteuer kann endlich beginnen
also ein weg ist ja noch zu erkennen
ich bestimme und er muss machen
hast du dir ein seepferdchen gemacht der
rote main
einer der beiden quellflüsse hat sich
neue wege gebahnt
ganz wichtig wird sagen belassen ok
die strömung ist ihnen zu gefährlich nun
also fünf kilometer umweg im
oberfränkischen auenland
das heißt ankunft am campingplatz nach
22 uhr drei stunden später als geplant
essen gibt es hier jetzt längst nicht
mehr nur noch drinks zelt aufbauen
sticht abendessen aber wie lehrt der
volksmund drei bier sind auch eine
mahlzeit
rossi
[Musik]
mein stadt melle lausitz stadthaus in
diesem corona sommerurlauben die
deutschen daheim und tatsächlich von
vielen unbemerkt hat nahe der deutsch
polnischen grenze die lausitz einen
beträchtlichen wandel durchgemacht
mehr als 20 künstlich angelegte sehen
sollen hier zu einem urlaubsparadies
werden hier versteckt sich die karibik
deutschlands denn das gebiet das mehr
als 150 jahre für den braunkohlebergbau
genutzt wurde hat ein neues gesicht
bekommen stillgelegten tagebauen wurden
geflutet und rekultiviert und durch
schiffbare kanäle miteinander verbunden
[Musik]
lange vergessene traditionen werden hier
wieder zum leben erweckt ja es gibt ihn
wieder rein aus der lausitz
dazu sandstrand stadt braunkohle
karibische exotik mit saft shop und
segelschule
was auch früher immer gewohnt nach
afrika oder asien oder in die arabischen
länder zu reisen und ja durch ihn er hat
mich jetzt hierhin gebracht und muss
sich auch mal erleben hey man muss ja
eigentlich gar nicht in den flieger
steigen um urlaubsfeeling zu haben und
was neues zu erleben
im dritten jahr kommen wir hierher man
hat hier in der lausitzer auch noch
immer eine besonderheit es gibt hier in
deutschland wüste das gibt es nirgends
anders die lausitzer wüste tonnenweise
sand aufgeschüttet auf alten bergbau
boden sie krohn und einer vagen die
safari im märkischen wüstensand ohne
wilde tiere zwar aber auf steilen pisten
durch das ehemalige gelände des
braunkohletagebaus klettwitz
[Musik]
si
ja
[Musik]
37 jahre sind die beiden erfurter jetzt
verheiratet und ohne corona hätten sie
die lausitz wohl auch in den nächsten 37
jahren nicht kennengelernt
ja das war erstmal eine herausforderung
sagt weil es erstmals nur so ist gelände
aber du hast mir ja gut 1 gewesen und da
hat das ganz gut geklappt muss jetzt
laufen ja ja ja auch ganz gut dann noch
so nicht hängen geblieben denn ist
sonnig
man denkt nicht dass man in deutschland
ist einfach super das war aufregend für
mich nur einmal erzähle ich sie auch mal
aus einer anderen perspektive ja das ist
traumhaft schöne muss ich sagen hätten
wir nicht gedacht
der charme der lausitz mit meinen augen
gesehen ist es genau das was wir hier
sehen
diese ehemalige tagebaulandschaft
teilweise nicht komplett durchsaniert
also auch noch spuren die man erfahren
betreten und erleben kann so wie hier
das ist für mich eigentlich das was die
lausitz ausmacht damit hat man auch die
verbundenheit zum tagebau zu den zum
bergbau von früher irgendwo noch heute
bleibt das zurück was einst das
lausitzer braunkohlerevier geprägt hat
der 11.000 tonnen schwere koloss eine
der größten beweglichen arbeitsmaschinen
der welt 80 meter hoch und längst nur
noch ein einmaliger aussichtspunkt
[Gelächter]
ein paar tage noch dann müssen sie grün
und rainer zurück aus ihrem neu
entdeckten paradies am nächsten morgen
in kulmbach in oberfranken
hier fließen die beiden quellflüsse
roter und weißer main zusammen bis nach
bamberg wo es mit i und thilo heute mit
dem fahrrad schaffen kulmbach ist schon
wach geküsst 40 prozent mehr
übernachtungen allein im letzten jahr
mit ihr und thilo wollen den main radweg
fahren und suchen jetzt das wasser
von wegen der mine nur der längste
nebenfluss des rheins eine
jahrhundertealte lebens aber bis heute
mitreißend
[Musik]
und die landschaft ist natürlich kein
richtiger an jeder kurve an das
berichtet unser feld pflanze machen
steht nach rosen wenn man durch die
erdbeer sämtliche rosen gerade blühen
also ist die nase ist das ein highlight
mit offener nase und offenen augen
entdecken mitte und thilo einer region
die weit mehr zu bieten hat als
schäufele und bier
natur pur und jede menge alte gemäuer
dieburg heißt eigentlich kloster banz
und zusammen mit der pilger basilika 14
linden und dem staffelberg ist dies das
fränkische dreigestirn dahin zum
beispiel hat einfach mal so eine riesen
kirche die da oben drauf steht
manchmal sind sogar licht und haben die
leute da eigentlich ein material hoch
geschleppt und dann sagt man wieder
schade dass wir da jetzt nicht abbiegen
können um dann aber muss man denn
wahrscheinlich im urlaub auch anders
plan
manch bayerisches heiligtum betrachten
die zwei preußischen atheisten aus
sicherer distanz von ihrem fahrrad auch
in der unesco welterbe stadt bamberg
bleibt es bei einer stippvisite
[Musik]
die beiden müssen weiter in drei tagen
wollen sie ja am rhein sein und die
loreley sie genau dort startet familie
dettinger in den urlaub vom mittelrhein
soll es über den hunsrück bis an die
mosel gehen ihre reise beginnt in sankt
goarshausen hier wacht die burg katz
über der sagenumwobenen stadt denn hier
steht er
der loreleyfelsen das berühmteste
wahrzeichen der region
[Musik]
die dettinger das leben eigentlich nur
100 kilometer flussaufwärts in hennef am
mittelrhein waren die vier trotzdem noch
nie aber jetzt corona sei dank den
überfüllten campingplatz lassen sie
links liegen
sie sind auf eigenen pfaden unterwegs
erst mal mit der fähre über den rhein
vorbei an postkartenmotiven wie dem
mäuseturm oberhalb des rheins der
hunsrück in rheinland pfalz das
mittelgebirge ist ein wanderparadies
familie dettinger ist auf dem
saar-hunsrück-steig unterwegs nach
wörsdorf um acht uhr morgens sind sie
aufgebrochen
denn wer die geier ley brücke für sich
alleine haben will muss früh dran sein
bei höhenangst wird die brücke zur
herausforderung
und sie ist eine der längsten
hängebrücken europas 360 meter
nervenkitzel
früher sagt bürgermeister markus
kirchhoff fuhrmann am hunsrück nur
vorbei aus der städtischen sicht war die
gegend hier eigentlich nicht zu besuchen
weil man der dauernd mit tieffliegern
rechneten mit krach und amerikanern und
zwar einfach wie eine tote gegend heute
entdecken urlauber die region neu das
ist durchaus lebenswert hier und ich
hoffe doch dass der hund zurück die
großen chancen erkennt die adia hat
im dorf oberheimbach eingebettet
zwischen ryan und weinbergen hat familie
dertinger für heute nacht einen
stellplatz gefunden
kempten unterm carport bei winzern aus
der region
ihren speziellen schlafplatz auf vier
rädern haben sie immer dabei
[Musik]
mit vereinten kräften wird der britschen
zum wohnwagen angebaut
langsam kommt camping feeling auf
[Musik]
tischlermeister bernd hat diese
wundertüte selbst konstruiert
[Musik]
ein carport im nirgendwo
nach einem vierteljahr im corona
lockdown fühlt sich das hier an wie ein
stück freiheit
freiheit hier hat sie noch viel mehr
bedeutung der thüringer wald bei oberhof
nahe der früheren innerdeutschen grenze
seit jahrzehnten urlaubsregion früher
schon die grüne lunge der ddr
[Musik]
und mittendrin beeindruckende
architektur jacqueline schambach ist
hier die chefin im panoramahotel oberhof
man hat hier eine tolle landschaft eine
tolle natur und wenn man hier oben steht
wenn der elften etage und rausguckt und
mal so ein bisschen wirken lässt
unbeschreiblich wenn sie das
panoramahotel sehen wissen sie es geht
um opel ist das panorama nicht im bild
ist oberhof im prinzip nur ein dorf im
wald früher nannte man das ihr sankt
moritz des ostens mittlerweile entdecken
den 160 kilometer lange rennsteig
wanderweg auch immer mehr urlauber aus
dem westen
doch auch die nostalgie touristen kommen
wieder nicht rein
es waren tolle zeiten für das haus ist
warm legendäre zeiten man kann es gar
nicht groß genug ausdrücken hat da war
die zeit als ich ausbildung gemacht habe
war das für uns etwas ganz großes nicht
erreichbar
vor gut 50 jahren wurde oberhof zum
kurort der werktätigen mit 900 betten
war das panoramahotel das größte
ferienhotel europas mit sieben
restaurants und kaminzimmer seltener
luxus im sozialismus
ich habe das haus zu hoch zeiten erlebt
zur ddr zeiten und auch kurz danach
und dann gab es viele jahre wo es doch
stückweise bergab ging
das hat weh getan das würden wir gerne
wieder ändern
da sind wir glaube ich ganz gut dabei
wir haben viel bewegt wir haben zu viel
renoviert werden man kann da mehr draus
machen vielmehr in diesem corona sommer
wagen sich nun auffallend viele aktiv
urlauber in die region
spannend dürfte werden ob sie
wiederkommen
[Musik]
wipfeld kilometer 180 vom main radweg
volkach ist heutiges etappenziel der
radfahrer hier wartet auf mit i und
thilo eine der schönsten fluss schleifen
europas
wir bleiben
hier bleiben wir bleiben schöne ecke
diese hohe hörste wieder keine geräusche
außer vogelgezwitscher
also wir fahren jetzt mit der fähre über
den verein schleifer und so verrichtet
highlight auf der ganzen tour von der
landschaft her
hast du eigentlich seekrank seit über 20
jahren hat sich erstmals wieder ein
storchenpaar niedergelassen und zieht in
seinem nest drei junge groß
[Musik]
die strecke umwelt und die mainschleife
gilt als eine der beliebtesten und
schönsten des ganzen wein radwegs
die mitte deutschlands gesäumt von
regionen von denen vor corona kaum einer
etwas wissen wollte entlang der
ehemaligen innerdeutschen grenze
schlängelt sich das grüne band
mittendrin die rhön und das örtchen
bircks am dreiländereck
[Musik]
nicht weit entfernt liegt die weide von
schäferin julia die abba mini hier hütet
sie ihre 140 ziegen und schafe die
schäferin wohnt in ihren berg mitten in
den grünen hügeln der rhön
mit ihrem spiegels hof hat sie sich
einen kindheitstraum erfüllt und
vermietet hier eine ferienwohnung
aber natürlich haben es kommen doch
nicht so viele leute wie wir eigentlich
hier verkraften könnten ihren gästen
bietet sie schafskäse 7 salami und
wandertouren ein ein frau betrieb
[Musik]
bis vor wenigen wochen konnte ich ja
nicht davon ausgehen dass ich das ganze
jahr über stehen werde
jetzt hat die nachfrage nach den
buchungen oder auch nach führungen ist
da nachdem also die nachfrage nach der
ferienwohnung ist sogar sehr stark
zugenommen
insofern kann ich jetzt tatsächlich
sagen dass ich ja so schlimm zeigen die
kinder als gewinnerin auf die situation
momentan rausgehen
[Musik]
durch die weinberge geht es richtung
zell an der mosel das herzstück der
region
die gegend ist bekannt als rentner
paradies aber hat sie noch mehr zu
bieten als barrierefreie unterkünfte die
weinstadt zell an der mosel schmiegt
sich hier an die zauberhafte
flusslandschaft
familie dettinger aber führt vorbei sie
haben noch ein anderes ein letztes ziel
ihrer reise entlang der engsten mose
schleife bis nach bremen
sie wollen mal wieder etwas neues
ausprobieren
und erster offizier kapitän
kanuverleiher peter kreuz wundert sich
selbst ein bisschen über den betrieb in
diesen wochen
normalerweise wenn man gar nicht hier
werden der toskana oder an der côte
d'azur oder in kroatien aber das hat sie
schon wissen gedreht kaum zu glauben
aber die mosel wird in corona sommer
tatsächlich zum urlaubsparadies
[Musik]
es wird ein trip durch eine imposante
landschaft vorbei am calmont den
steilsten weinberg europas am ende für
alle ein unvergesslicher paddel ausflug
in einer der vielleicht am meisten
unterschätzten urlaubsregionen
deutschlands hier an der mosel endet
unsere reise durch wachgeküsst regionen
vorbei an altehrwürdigen orten und
blinden flecken auf der touristischen
landkarte die nur darauf warten entdeckt
zu werden
[Musik]